okay keep in mind keep it in mind keep
it in mind keep in mind you know D have
to to keep it in mind kasia's hello this
is he well you see I had this memory
condition so I probably would remember
you anyway in fact I'm having a hard
time remembering what I'm supposed to do
right now look at my polaroid my only
anyone have a pullover these things are
extinct polaroid photos in my pocket
that's right I review movies I'm like a
huge movie fan that's right
fucking love movies hey thanks man you
made me remember my whole life I'll
probably forget it in like eight seconds
but thanks speaking of which I have to
go and film a review bye please where
was I
momento was directed by Christopher
Nolan and stars Guy Pearce as a very
psychologically damaged individual he is
dealing with very short-term memory loss
he can't remember anything after a very
short time he forgets everyone that he
knows almost instantly he has to be
reminded of things all the time he takes
pictures of things Polaroids to remember
things he writes notes down on them and
this movie is one of my favorites I've
loved it for many years and I'm really
excited to talk about it in 2005 when
Batman Begins was coming out a lot of my
friends weren't very excited about it I
can't really blame them because the last
one was Batman and Robin but because of
movies like memento I had a lot of
confidence when I heard that Christopher
Nolan was going to be directing Batman
Begins my friends hadn't seen memento
and I was really championing it and I
was trying to get them to watch it and
eventually they did of course and it's
one of those movies where the first time
you see it if you know nothing about it
going in this movie will blindside you
it will take you by such surprise
because of how clever it is there really
is no other movie like memento and
that's something I love about it and
that's something that you can't deny
this movie is wholly original and that's
rare
that's really rare to find a movie that
truly is as original as memento our main
hero with Leonard played by Guy Pearce
and as I said he has extreme short-term
memory loss things fade almost instantly
he's also trying to solve a murder that
of his wife's she was raped and killed
and because of this incident he attacked
one of the killers and he got hurt and
now we can't remember anything for very
long
so he has tattoos all over his body that
are helping him solve various crimes
when he discovers what he thinks are
facts that will lead him to the killer
of his wife he tattoos them to his body
so that he can never forget them
he conditions himself to remember how to
be a person still because one of the
plot holes with this movie is how does
he remember that he has this condition
how is he not just some guy wandering on
the street constantly forgetting
everything how is he able to maintain
some level of credibility as a human
being well he talked about it in the
film actually he was able to condition
himself mentally through repetition
through instincts to do these things
over and over again so that he can
remember how to live and specifically
remember what he's living for now which
is revenge if all of this isn't
confusing enough as a narrative the real
impressive thing that no one was able to
do with this movie is play the movie
completely out of order there are
black-and-white scenes that are
sequential when he's talking to someone
on the phone and you learn about a past
history with a man who had serious
memory problems and his wife who was
trying to get insurance from guy
Pearce's old insurance company which is
what he used to do so the
black-and-white sequences are in the
correct order but the colorized
sequences are incomplete reverse order
so you get all those scenes split up
like that and the movie plays reverse
chronologically and forward
chronologically which is why you cannot
just watch this movie once I've watched
this movie probably 20 times and I've
loved it more and more every time I
watch it because inevitably I discover
something new every time and that's the
genius of this movie with the film being
structured like that as well as the
intentional continuity errors that no
one has inserted into the film it makes
you feel like you have Leonard's
condition like you're just struggling to
find all the pieces to assemble a
cohesive narrative and it's so brilliant
it's it's rather ingenious actually and
memento is a film that if you haven't
seen and yet you have an appreciation
for movies you have to see it it's one
of those musts this is a Fight Club this
is a 12 Angry Men this is a Pulp Fiction
memento in my mind is one of the best
movies ever made it's a must for film
fans and that's why I'm not going to get
into spoiler
if you haven't seen memento because I
feel like some of you maybe have it and
I don't want to ruin it for you I do
want to talk about Guy Pearce he is so
damn good in this movie I think this is
one of the most underrated performances
of the 2000s decade I think he's
brilliant in this movie he rattled off
lines so fast and with such ease it
feels like he is just such a natural
presence in this movie and if you ever
actually have been on a set and watched
the way actors work you know how
difficult it is to sometimes get really
long monologue sequences out with no
problems Guy Pearce makes it look like
he's just strolling through the park
it's a fantastic performance and I don't
think it gets enough praise Joe
Pantoliano is also really entertaining
in the movie as is carrie-anne moss in
the end what memento proved to me a long
time ago the first time I saw it is that
you do not need a gigantic budget to
make a great film that can inspire an
entire generation you can make a great
film if you have a great story and if
you have talented people working with
you and memento is one of the shining
examples of that it's a fantastic film
it's mind-bending its original it's
extremely extremely exciting filmmaking
I'm going to give memento an A+ so guys
thank you so much as always for watching
this review I really appreciate it look
forward to my reviews of the prestige as
well as insomnia which I'm going to be
doing with my friend Matt Brando I can't
wait to bring those reviews to you guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]